there joining me now are the founder and
president of parents defending education
Nicole Neely and Manhattan Institute
senior fellow Chris rufo Nicole let's
start with you um are we winning or
losing the war against Dei given this
effort to rebranded as something
regarding
Excellence it is an astonishing gessling
that's taking place I mean this is
certainly a many-headed Hydra but I
think the fact that they're in Retreat
really shows that people like have
really made an impact um because at the
end of the day it's not that Dei has
oops we accidentally miscoded Jews and
Asians as oppressors when they should be
oppressed it's that our public schools
and our tax dollars are youing are being
used to code people at all and so until
we really actually put this in the grave
I think we can't give up now Chris when
they're caught as they were in this case
like oh we don't we we no longer use
that right but next week is black lives
matter week in schools and um and it's a
week of action and they're actually even
selling merchandise okay shirts
sweatshirts even a journal all to help
promote their demands and again brand
this agenda as pro-education
um Pro you know Excellence Etc so talk
about propaganda they even have their
own merch
line yeah and it's really not about
Excellence you'll notice that a lot of
the language is not about uh propping up
black students teach black students the
skills they'll need to succeed but
actually it's about scapegoating white
students white Educators uh White
leaders and uh we become so habituated
to this uh anti-white discrimination
coming from the education sector that we
almost forget how shocking it should be
but if we're merely to switch the names
of some of those groups it'll give you a
sense of it I mean imagine we're in 20th
century Europe and we have uh teachers
pledging to commit and I'll read with
the exact words from Denver School
District with the group group swapped a
commitment to German Excellence that all
Educators need to deeply understand
Jewish Supremacy Jewish privilege and
the Deep harm jewishness brings to
students and team members uh that is
shocking it's abominable but it's the
exact same terminology with the groups
switched that we're seeing in places
like Denver public schools make no
mistake about it this is an awful
ideology that judges people on Race uh
it should have no place in our
institutions it's obscene and as you
were saying that this Robin D'Angelo
who's one of the more
intolerant um Pro Dei uh Educators out
there she tells the Denver schools and
this is in their literature that it is
not that if you are racist but how you
are racist we all perpetuate racist
ideologies policies and practice in some
way and must work tirelessly in our
efforts to be
anti-racist um so in other words you
know yeah of course everyone's a racist
it's just a matter of degree
that's absolutely right and the simple
fact too in Denver is that white
students make up only about 20% of the
student body and so it's not the case
that this is a kind of targeted
scapegoating style rhetoric directed
towards the majority that's not
acceptable either but it actually is
directed towards a numerical absolute
minority uh I think it's disgraceful uh
it it it goes under this moniker of
anti-racism but uh uh it's nothing of
short it's racist what they're doing is
racist Nicole and Chris keep at it keep
up the great work and thank
you thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else